I believe that the purpose of sport is
to tell us what we're capable as a
species what the human body is capable
of if you know that people are enhanced
by definition they're not like us well I
think you actually have to distinguish
what you've said there you've said the
purpose of sport is to show us what
we're capable of as a species and then
you said purpose of sport is to show us
what we're capable of as individual
humans both both right and as a species
scientific progress is probably our
greatest asset and so we are at the
enhanced games so visibly illustrating
the capabilities of athletic Excellence
individual athletic Excellence plus
Collective scientific progress but
doesn't the word enhanced in the title
imply
on human inhuman better than human
absolutely and shouldn't we aspire to be
better than what we are today something
greater